i've got some matrix a we learned
several videos ago that its row space is
the same thing as the column space
of its transpose of its transpose so
that right there is the
row space row space
of a
that this thing's orthogonal complement
so the set of all of the vectors that
are orthogonal to this so its orthogonal
complement is equal to the null space of
a
and
essentially the same result if you
switch a and a transpose
we also learned that the orthogonal
complement of the column space of a
the orthogonal complement of the column
space of a
is equal to the left null space
of a which is the same thing as the null
space of a transpose so we could write
this just to understand the terminology
that's the left null space left null
space which is the same thing as a null
space of a transpose
now what about
what is the orthogonal complement of the
null space of a
what is the orthogonal complement of the
null space of a
well you might guess that it's the row
space of a but we didn't have the tools
until the last video to figure that out
in the last video we saw
that
if we take the orthogonal complement let
me write it this way if we were to take
the orthogonal complement of the
orthogonal complement it equals the
original subspace
so now what are we doing we're taking
the orthogonal complement of the null
space of a well the null space of a is
just this thing right here the null
space of a is that thing right there so
this is equal to
taking the orthogonal complement of the
null space of a
but the null space of a is this thing
it's the column it's the row spaces
it's the row spaces orthogonal
complement
now we're essentially taking the
orthogonal complement of the orthogonal
complement so we can use this property
which we just proved in the last video
to say that this is equal to
just the row space of a
which is the same thing as the column
space of a transpose so the orthogonal
complement of the row space is the null
space and the orthogonal complement of
the null space is the row space we can
apply that same property on this side
right here
what is
what is the orthogonal complement
what is the orthogonal complement of the
left null space
the left null space of a what is this
well this is going to be equal to the
orthogonal complement of
this thing because that's what the left
null space of a is equal to so it's
equal to the orthogonal complement of
the orthogonal complement
of the column space
and we just learned in the last video if
you take the orthogonal complement of
your orthogonal complement it equals the
original subspace
so this is just equal to the column
space of a so we just we now see some
nice symmetry the null space is the
orthogonal complement of the row space
and then we see that the row space is
the orthogonal complement of the null
space similarly the left null space is
the orthogonal complement of the column
space and the column space is the
orthogonal complement of the left null
space so we have some nice symmetry that
we're able to
essentially prove given what we saw in
the last video